[Musique]
quatre minutes montre en main c'est le
temps record qu'il faut pour assembler
morphose un robot collaboratif
entièrement automatisée imaginé et conçu
ici à belfort on part d'un robot
totalement aux pièces détachées convient
assemblée suivant la configuration qui
est nécessaire pour le travail qui va
devoir réaliser on peut le montrer que
dans un seul sens que d'une certaine
manière qui fait qu'ils s'arrangent son
son assemblage accessible à tous au pt
une fois en marche morphose peut servir
de support à de très nombreux outils
l'objectif ici on nous l'assurent n'est
pas de remplacer la main de l'homme mais
bien de l'accompagner dans ses
différentes tâches les clients
potentiels sont sont très nombreux par
exemple on a dit il ya des robots comme
aux tic qui font déjà des par exemple
des pizzas qui est des médecins faire
des scanners des choses comme ça qui est
de par exemple dans la dans le
maquillage
par exemple à faire les tests maquillage
des choses comme ça tous les les
applications on a besoin de répétabilité
pour concevoir ce robot unique en france
il a fallu trois ans de travail à julien
morel et ses équipes les cinq premiers
robots sont vendus et
et on a deux partenaires en cours de
discussion dans l'innovation déjà
récompensés l'an dernier sa start up a
reçu une aide de plus d'un million
d'euros dans le cadre du plan de relance
on a gagné au moins deux ans grâce à ce
soutien de l'état et à ce niveau là on
peut on peut être que plein de gratitude
aujourd'hui il ya d'ekobo dans le monde
il n'y a pas de kobo français mais
d'ekobo modulaire il y en a aucun dans
le monde donc cette prouesse technique
là on est en train d'essayer de la
mettre en place et ça permet de garantir
l'agilité du produit c'est à dire que
même des gens qui sont pas sûrs pour
utiliser un produit tout le temps de
manière répétée et ben ils auront toutes
les gammes de produits disponibles en un
seul produit l'objectif désormais pour
la jeune start-up belfortaine trouver
des partenaires et faire valider son
kobo par de potentiels futurs clients